let's sound the trumpets for these
fallen heroes even if some of them
return before their corpses get cold
also beware there are spoilers ahead
in the world of the X-Men Charles Xavier
devise a complex process to literally
resurrect any member of homo Superior
who no longer resides among the living
this process involves cerebro
automatically backing up the memories of
every mutant on the planet as well as
Hope Summers tempus Proteus Elixir and
egg all combining their powers so if
Wolverine actually perishes in a
definitive way like he did in Logan hope
and her crew known as the five will make
sure he's back and even better at what
he does by the next morning however in
order to bring a mutant back Professor X
and the five have to remember that
mutants existed this creates a special
problem for a member of the legionnaires
known as forget me not his power is an
inability to register in the memory of
other beings while it might be
particularly useful in keeping a low
profile it doesn't Aid him in the comics
during Legion of X issue 10 the
Sentinels attack krakowa and
forget-me-not gives his own life in
order to protect the island a techno
organic being known as warlock also
perishes in the scaffold but the
surviving legionnaires immediately begin
laying plans to reassemble him as far as
Forget Me Not is concerned it's
impossible to bring back a dead person
if you don't remember they ever existed
in the first place
in case anyone who watched Ant-Man and
the Wasps Quantum Mania needs a quick
reminder the glowing cylinder-headed
zalam is a dead giveaway that somebody
from the Rick and Morty writing staff
had a strong hand in Scott Lang's big
screen Adventure unfortunately it
appears as if this is the one and done
deal for the Whimsical and eccentric
Marvel character after his fate in the
movie despite his lack of a backstory or
really much of an identity Beyond his
warrior-like disposition and the lines
with the quantum realm Rebels audiences
felt a slight tuck on their heartstrings
when Kang popped zalim's head granted it
might have been a very slight tug since
no one really knew who he was but as far
as quantumania characters go xylem
definitely does more to further the plot
than the likes of Lord kreiler or hope
Van Dyne zalam didn't deserve a lot
better than them but maybe he deserved a
little better here
the mcu's infamously overworks digital
designers that the best they could to
turn Corey stole into a giant head with
proportionately tiny arms and legs
whether they pulled it off or not might
be a matter for another debate but it's
clear the character known as a
mechanized organism designed only for
killing or simply Modoc isn't expected
to appear in future MCU films after
cassilang reminds Kang's most ridiculous
henchmen that he doesn't need to be such
a horrible person Modoc takes her advice
to heart and vice seduce for helping an
army of giant ants Vanquish the quantum
Realms one-time conqueror with his dying
breath he looks into the eyes of his
former Arch Enemy Scott Lang and says
and at least I died
an Avenger
Modoc can't legitimately declare himself
an Avenger and Scott probably doesn't
have the clout to approve new members
modoc's last second turn to the heroic
side is enough to qualify him for this
list
they're not baby legs by splitting his
12 episode season 4 and half Titans made
sure he wouldn't know if Jing survived
getting stabbed in the girth with a
magic Pitchfork in episode 6. it's only
in episode 7 that we learn Jinx doesn't
make it and does another superhero
casualty off the show joining the likes
of Hawk she receives a nice send-off
though as Raven sends a fragments of
jinx's soul to be at peace in the
afterlife and that's apparently that for
the character Jing to the recent
addition to the Titans TV show having
made her first appearance in season 4's
third episode appropriately titled Jinx
however she has a rich history in the
comics going all the way back to Marv
wolfman's 1980s run on Teen Titans
interestingly enough she has been
portrayed mostly as a villain in the DC
Universe and as a member of the road
group known as The Fearsome five well at
least she had a chance to experience
being a superhero in Titans
there were only four certainties in life
death taxes superhero death and the
retconning of said superhero death
besides taxes the rest happens in Shazam
Fury of the Gods as a titular hero
himself meets his maker even if it is
only for a brief period of time and no
one believed it would be final Billy
Batson fails to survive a battle against
the film's ultimate antagonist the evil
goddess Calypso who is also one of the
daughters of Atlas however Billy's death
is very temporary here in the end the
Wonder Woman makes a surprise come here
and brings him back to life in a
scenario that makes Krakow and mutant
Resurrection look plausible by
comparison at the same time it makes the
whole concept of death rather pointless
in the DC Universe if Wonder Woman knows
all about magic and resurrection and can
revive others why didn't she do the same
for Superman in Batman and v Superman
dawn of Justice as well then no one was
about to mess with the mother boxes in
Justice League
while Shazam receives a second chance at
life in Shazam Fury of the Gods the same
doesn't hold true for the Greek goddess
hespera who knows maybe Wonder Woman
wasn't a fan of hespera and they had
beef a lifetime ago hence why the Amazon
didn't bother to even think about
Reviving her Casper's softer story as
one of the main villains and appears to
be the big part of the movie however she
switched his sides and fights on behalf
of order and decency before the final
credits roll unfortunately her
Redemption Arc does come at the highest
price as she perishes from the wounds of
the fighting her sister Calypso who has
nefarious plans of her own to be fair
most villains do tend to meet their
maker in comic book movies and even if
espera didn't about turn to join the
good side what else could she do from a
storytelling perspective in the DC
Universe but you will never be a true
God
Tom King and Greg smallwoods the human
target starts with Christopher Chance
Downing a tumbler full of poisoned
whiskey intended for the gullet of the
evil Lex Luthor as per the story the
poison would take 12 days to go through
him and claim his life however as a
reader moves through the series it
always feels like there's a possibility
that the human target might manage to
outrun the Grim Reaper before it's too
late but that doesn't prove to be the
case here as he dies from the poison
right on schedule in the 12th issue
anybody who has paid attention to DC
Comics in modern times knows King tends
to set his 12-issue Maxi Series in their
own individualized elseworld timelines
this way he and his collaborators can
decide what to do with the characters
without having any real ramifications
for the main timeline but whether or not
the human target is considered
canonically dead in the primary DC
Universe this series deserves mention it
also acts as another reminder of how
King is a masterful ability to make us
care about c-list heroes such as what he
did with Mr miracle in the 2017
mini-series a human target might perish
here but does so in Unforgettable Style
heading into director James Gunn's final
installment of his Guardians of the
Galaxy Trilogy plenty of fans are
pricing themselves for a bloodbath of
Epic Proportions after all Dave Batista
and Zoe Saldana had indicated a strong
interest in moving away from Marvel
while in the trailers Rocket Raccoon and
Star-Lord both look like they're in
pretty rough shape for all we knew gun
would blast the whole zany crew to
Oblivion on his way out the door and
truly close the chapter on this team as
it turns out the Guardians themselves
all survived the events but Gunn found a
totally unexpected way to break our
hearts and Trigger the tears in
flashbacks to Rocket raccoon's early
years of the living experiment on the
high evolutionary space laboratory we
meet young Rocket's adorable cell mates
and Pals Lila the utter thiefs the
walrus and Flor the rabbit one thing
leads to another and Rocket devises a
scheme with the intention to bring his
new Buddies along with him to Freedom
the high evolutionary has other plans
though and establishes himself as a
truly heinous villain a cruelly
annihilating Lila thieves and floor
Thanos might have destroyed half the
world's population with a snap of his
fingers the high evolutionary's actions
feel slightly more evil here these
beloved characters deaths are a moment
that not only devastates rocket but also
the audience watching most of us weren't
prepared to see these adorable creatures
executed in such a devastating way
and we'll kill anyone who gets in our
way no not kill anyone drawing the last
episode of the Titans TV show Superboy
spends quite a while lying motionless on
a table as his lungs and heart do
positively nothing it appears as if he
is well and truly cooked here in the
interest of full disclosure let's notice
comrades and the Titans never seem all
that distressed about his apparent
passing except for maybe Beast Boy and
when Connor kenz comes back and asks if
he died nobody gives a definitive answer
maybe Superboy doesn't die enough for
the Titans to qualify it in their minds
but he dies enough for us since he looks
dead for a hot minute probably the most
interesting character in the final
season of Titans Superboy leans into the
Lex Luthor side of his genetic Heritage
throughout much of these 12 episodes
naturally he realizes the error of his
ways and rejoins his friends when he
starts to think he can't shut down by
the blood on his own his theory proves
to be correct as Brother Blood is the
one who Nails him with a highly charged
magic bolt that proves fatal initially
it is also yet another reminder that
kryptonians are only vulnerable to
Kryptonite but also Magic
[Music]